hey folks this josh tarney rich farmer
welcome to the farm blog today today
we're going to be working with the
tractor and the seed drill this is a
no-till seed drill made by hey buster
and we're going to be busting some hay
so we're gonna go out and all these bare
spots throughout the field and all the
land down here that we just had cleared
and you can see it's a whole lot of land
where we've got it cleared all down
through there we're gonna seed this land
okay so we've got fescue rye grass and
rye grain and that's what we're going to
be putting in here and also medium
Ladino clover so come along on the farm
vlog today we're gonna have a little bit
of fun loading up the hopper will show
you how it all works and we'll get out
of here and we'll drill some grain we'll
drill some grass seed and get this thing
started alright let's have some fun
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I put this part in the vlog I was
going to cut it out but I just wanted
you to see what a struggle it is
sometimes just to hook up a piece of
equipment and I sped it up right here
but it took me nearly ten minutes just
to put this pin in you can see what a
struggle if you're not strong you really
can't do this kind of stuff so I get a
lot of flack for having a belly but man
you got to be a strong guy to handle
this kind of stuff it's it's big
equipment really hard alright guys this
is called the hey buster okay there are
three hoppers on this hey buster won't
take you up top and show you that here
in just a second but we're gonna walk
around first and we'll get it hooked to
the tractor okay I'll show you what we
have to do here we are at the back of
the seed drill here okay
these tubes that you're seeing down here
is what the seed drops down into okay
and we'll show you how all the
adjustments work this is the hydraulic
setup and these two hydraulic lines
right here go straight over here I have
some zip ties all set these zip ties
down they go right over here into our
rear secondary hydraulics okay so we'll
give them a little wipe down it's good
to have gloves for this and we'll pop
our secondary hydraulics loose right
there okay now here our hydraulics we
don't want our secondaries this is for
the front the grapple on the front of
the tractor we don't want them flopping
around here so that's why we have zip
ties
so we'll zip tie these guys up to where
they'll be in a good safe place out of
the way and they won't get pinched ask
me how I learned this okay alright guys
so here are hydraulic lines and we'll
hook those into our rear secondary
remotes and all you do is just push them
into place and they lock right in just
like this okay and they're locked into
place now we need to take a look at our
Dalek lines now our hydraulic line
cannot just be flopping around all over
everywhere but we see they've already
put some rope on here and the rope is
kind of loose so we got to know this is
what happens when they flop around
everywhere they'll get pinched right
inside there so
we've got to find a way to support these
and once again that's why we need our
zip ties so what I learned last time is
you got to take care of your hydraulic
line so we'll go down here with our zip
tie and we'll just zip tie this guy
right up here to our three-point hitch
thing I forgot what that's called guys
tell me what that thing's called I
forgot what it was what it's called I
know everybody knows what it is so now
you can see our hydraulic lines are
free-floating but they're not gonna get
into anything down here okay next thing
we'll show you how to adjust the hoppers
okay so there's a step here a step here
then you get up on this rail right here
okay I'm tall enough that I can reach up
here put the lid up when you flip the
lid you've got a guide right here that
tells you what you're running and tells
you what settings to put it on so we put
it on setting number eight for fescue
and that puts 23 you see the 23 that's
23 pounds per acre and then we have some
settings for the spring in the rear and
a few more settings to set our depth for
the drill and this is the drill part the
little blades that you see down there so
we'll go right over here and there's a
little hand crank there's a little crank
and there's a little dial right here and
we want to set it on eight by cranking
our little crank just like that so here
we go
cranking it cranking it right there to
the eight that's a little above the
eight yeah there we go looks good now
we'll be putting down some rye grain
right there's a rye grain and we want to
put the raw grain down we're gonna put
it on the number five at 15 okay and
that puts 15 pounds to the acre we want
to put the Rye grain and the rye grass
seed down because it's an annual and
it's going to come up really really fast
now we're on a hillside right here and
this hillside will wash so we want
something that's going to hit quick okay
hitting quick means it's going to grow
it's going to grow quick so it's going
to sprout a root within a day a day day
and a half that rye grain will and then
the ryegrass will follow about four days
later and then the fescue will follow
about seven to nine to twelve days later
so we'll get on our crank right here and
we'll start cranking until this guy gets
on the five okay it's set wide open
14 right now so actually something's
crunching in there Oh looks like we've
still got some wheat down in here so
that being said we'll find the setting
for wheat and we'll set it on what we
want the wheat to be ed now I was told
when I got this thing that it had some
wheat in it did I want the wheat taken
out and I said no no we'll just drill it
down in two so we'll take the wheat and
we'll run around and we'll drill with
the wheat just a little bit on some top
edges and some really like steep spots
now the setting for wheat and we want to
dump it out as fast as we can we'll
probably put the wheat at and let's just
dump it we'll put it up twelve okay
we're gonna get rid of that week now the
rear hopper is a little bit different
it's four clover seed if you look up in
there that's for a smaller seed and I'll
show you so the seeds are caught by this
little gear right here
and here's the adjuster you slide that
left to right and the gear slides left
to right so that's how much it's open
however much gear is exposed inside of
this tells you how much seed you're
gonna have down and we're gonna set it
we're gonna take it all the way to zero
and we're just gonna barely open it to
one right there is the one and it's a
dial right there okay we tighten up the
little wing nut okay now there's another
one we repeat this process right there
there's another one on the other side so
this is two separate compartments I
don't know how that rat got there but
that's gross
let's talk about the undercarriage let's
talk about what we have here okay so
this wheel helps to guide this wheel
right here rolls along the ground and
turns a shaft and that shaft goes up
through here and turns everything that's
moving in this machine and it also turns
an hour meter so right there is well
it's not an hour meter it's an acre
meter right there it'll tell you
ninety-eight revs per acre pretty cool
and all these little chains and doodads
I'm not going to go into total detail
but when it's moving it's moving
everything on here is moving these tubes
are what the seeds fall through and they
fall down through these tubes and they
fall down through these tubes it's
pretty cool this whole thing has a
suspension setup so it goes up and down
and follows the con
tour of the land so you take these
blades right here and they're rubbing
each other they're spinning freely
they're rubbing each other and on the
backside they're open we'll take you
around and show you that but they open
up the land they drop the seed in and
then this little wheel right here comes
in and mashes it down so that's a
no-till drill and there's the backside
okay that's what you see on the backside
so it opens the soil drops the seed and
then this little wheel presses it down
okay so the next step here is we're
gonna hop up and we're gonna start
dumping grass seed in first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna load up this
platform right here with grass seed so
let's get busy doing that all right this
is our Kentucky 32 fescue it's an end of
fight free fescue for cattle pretty cool
now we're gonna go up here on the
platform and dump in our seed all right
up on the platform get our fiscal you up
there and basically we're gonna cut our
bags open
okay so guys this is Kentucky 32 fescue
worried about $85 a bag on this there's
how many bags four bags in there right
now
that'll get us a good start and we have
one two three four seven more bags that
we're going to put out okay this will
all even out as we hit bumps and smooth
out okay pretty cool
now the next hopper we're going to use
is going to be our wheat hopper okay so
we're going to go ahead and burn through
that wheat we're going to take a little
bit ride a little bit around here and
get these spots that are in the middle
of the field first and get that wheat
out of there we're also going to load
the clover hopper and I'll show you the
clover hopper right here will close the
week and here's the clover hopper that's
what it looks like inside pretty simple
will load the clover hopper up and get
going with that now the clover cost one
hundred and twenty dollars for a
50-pound bag we're doing about
twenty-five to thirty acres here that'll
totally cover that you might be asking
hey why is he putting clover in with his
fescue
I'm putting clover in with my fescue for
the first few years to get it
established well clover fixes nitrogen
to the soil fescue loves nitrogen we're
going to feed that grass seed and then
we'll probably go over it with a
herbicide to kill the broadleaf at some
point maybe we may go organic and we may
not use herbicides at all now the reason
that I'm putting the clover seed down is
because of a man named Joel Salatin he
wrote a book called salad bar beef I'll
post a link down below if you want to
raise your cows on a salad bar it's
pretty cool it's interesting book to
read and I went up to Polyface farm
where Joel's farm is if you've never
heard of him then I'm surprised you're
on this channel really really cool guy
nice place and what I noticed on his
farm was lots of clover in the fields
the fields were beautiful in green and I
think the element that was making them
beautiful in green was that clover
fixing that nitrogen that's a little bit
more difficult to get up here and put
your seed in here for your clover okay
and I'll show you the clover seed here
in a minute
the rye grass seed looks a whole lot
like just grass the Rye grain is just a
little bit smaller than wheat like I
everybody knows what wheat looks like
but the clover is totally totally
different this is what the clover looks
like it's little beads so it's a little
bit more cumbersome to do the clover get
to be real careful these are separate
hoppers let's and make sure you get a
even amount in each hopper which we do
not have but at least we try so it's a
good idea to have a like a measuring cup
or a glass or a you know a cup or
something so you can even it out a
little bit and that's what we're gonna
do so we're gonna get to drilling okay
see you on the tractor guys be sure your
butt is always in the seat when you're
starting a tractor okay contact
okay guys what you're going to see here
is this hydraulic cylinder going up
taking a little bit of tension off okay
now the tension is off and we're going
to pull these pins right here well I
thought the tension was off we've got a
lever on the back of the tractor that
raises and lowers by controlling the
cylinder right here we're gonna raise it
up a little bit okay so we're going to
pull this pin right here out comes the
pin this little red guy kind of sits out
of the way and put our pin back in here
make sure it doesn't get gone and then
this whole cylinder will lower down to
the ground all right I'm gonna lower the
cylinder down now what we just did was
set these down on the ground
and set that wheel in motion that ATV
looking tire as that tire rolls it'll
start putting seed in the ground pretty
cool
[Applause]
[Music]
just a few more things that you need to
know when you're going around a sharp
turn with this thing you have to raise
it up and then when you start going
straight again you lower it back down so
you're constantly raising and lowering
and checking your hoppers I just check
to see if that wheat was gone it's not
quite gone yet but probably another 15
minutes of drilling and it'll all be
gone
I'm gonna go breathe a little bit of
dust have some fun so folks we got a lot
of work ahead of us and we're gonna say
bye from here I appreciate you please
come on back and see us on the Stoney
Ridge farm click that like button
subscribe to the channel please
subscribe subscribe if I didn't say it
already subscribe we need you here on
the star neeraj farm come on back and
see us sometime click the like button
we'll see you next time here on the
stern orig farmer
thanks guys see you next time
[Music]